allein sie meinen ja mundschutz und der
fusions mittel kriegt man hier genug in
deutschland aber im moment wer in der
altenpflege sehen davor nichts wir
bekommen alle irgendwo es jetzt im
moment und das klatschen bringt uns auch
nicht viel in der altenpflege wie wärs
man mit einer gehaltserhöhung für uns
allen danke ihnen ich bin mal gespannt
auf ihre antwort viele grüße aus
villingen die simone jetzt verstehe ich
die simone gut dass das sie auch sagt
umfragen einfach hat moment mal was ist
eigentlich bin jeden tag im einsatz auch
mit pflegebedürftigen mit kolleginnen
und kollegen und ich brauchte auch in
schutz und deswegen desinfektionsmittel
und masken aber das ist ja genau das was
ich gerade gesagt habe daran arbeiten
wir tag und nacht bei
desinfektionsmitteln gelingt es deutlich
schneller jetzt auch für entlastung zu
sorgen als bei den schuttmassen was die
bezahlung angeht sagt er ist in der
altenpflege tätig haben wir jetzt auch
vor
corona schon über bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und bezahlungen nicht
nur geredet sondern auch entschieden es
gibt einen deutlich höheren mindestlohn
in der altenpflege richtung jetzt 2600
euro schrittweise geht es in der
vollzeit das ist schon mal wichtig das
ist für viele zigtausende
altenpflegekräfte in deutschland eine
deutliche verbesserung und gleichzeitig
mache ich mir auch gedanken ist aber
auch dann die frage wie man muss es ja
auch fair machen wie man all denjenigen
die jetzt in dieser zeit besonders mit
anpacken
in den kliniken in den praxen im
gesundheitswesen in der pflege wie man
da auch noch mal am ende sagen kann das
wollen wir auch finanziell noch mal
besonders vergüten der finanzminister
als eher möglich gemacht das ist jetzt
auch steuerfrei einen bonus geben kann
und ich würde gerne zusammen mit den
arbeitgebern schauen wie wir wege finden
auch diejenigen die da jetzt großartiges
leisten jeden tag dafür nochmal eine
besondere anerkennung zu geben
das ist übrigens nämlich leichter gesagt
ich sehe immer die forderungen ist ein
bonus für alle zeit ich verstehe die
forderung gut aber die frage wie man das
fair und gerecht macht und das
tatsächlich dann auch ankommen lässt bei
denen dies erhalten sollen die ist dann
nicht ganz so schnell in der umsetzung
gemacht da freue ich mich auch über
jeden guten vorschlag die idee finde ich
aber richtig und darüber möchte ich
gerne auch mit den arbeitgebern in der
pflege rede